the cheapest way to make your own
swimming pool and a bus who thinks he's
the kool-aid man it's episode five of
IMG we begin the day with hoodies that
zip up to make you look like Captain
America a ninja Batman or Boba Fett last
week BuzzFeed gave us Warner Brothers
cartoons for adults
and obese animals
[Music]
today reddit has a awesome but painful
tattoo no not a cornea tattoo but a
tattoo on the inside of the upper lip
that lets you do this we've had a lot of
cool illusions on the show and a few
episodes ago I showed you rotating
snakes but this week I found a version
that's even more intense for me almonds
move your eyes from shape to shape and
the picture will Bend in war seriously
pause the video it'll still move in the
last episode of IMG I tricked some of
you into touching my butt well guess
what
YouTube remembers if you touched my butt
and liked it YouTube knows your name and
has added you to the registry of butt
touches you'll know you're on the list
because all of a sudden this video will
just freeze and you'll have to
okay now that the butt touches are gone
let's get on with the show
on Digg yesterday we met John John ray
which reminds me of last week when
banned in Hollywood collected 25
horribly awesome names including Harry :
dr. porn sack BJ cobble dick dick bender
that one Batman bends Superman and Jesus
condoms that does it for this episode of
IMG we'll be back next Monday but in the
meantime check out facebook.com slash
vsauce gaming that's where you guys get
to submit your favorite images from the
week and you guys have done such a
fantastic job that it's become a
treasure trove of hilarious stuff so
keep them coming
my favorite submission from this week
was just a simple location shot hotel
casts big deal right bonus to figure out
what exactly is going on into this
picture you'll have to stay tuned
Wednesday for my special interview with
black nerd comedy and to check out
previous episodes of IMG click any of
the links below thanks a lot for
watching have a great day
[Music]